so as we pick up with the Avengers
disassembled to issue number three what
we find here is that we're going to be
covering the death of Hawkeye now this
was a very big moment in Marvel Comics
and the reason why is because while
Hawkeye was a background character while
he had never had his own solo series
there was always a more or less just
part of the Avengers Hawkeye was still a
fan favorite among a lot of Marvel
Comics fans and so when Marvel came
along and killed Hawkeye off there was a
huge amount of backlash a lot of fans
absolutely hated this and so what we'll
find as we get into next year when we do
the House of M event as well find that
Marvel will actually bring Hawkeye back
due solely to the fact that so many fans
wanted to see him return and so what we
do is we begin this story is we pick up
where we left off with part two and we
have all these different Avengers both
present and former as well as I guess
associates of the Avengers meeting at
Avengers mansion and indeed Captain
America asks why it is that they're all
here and what they say we're at least at
Aulis speak something on behalf of them
is he says that they were all Avengers
at one point in time either they were
very close to the Avengers team or they
were Avengers proper and so when the
white-white call distress saying oh the
white code distress signal had went out
that was a signal that went out to
everybody who was associated with the
Avengers or who was an Avenger and so
they all answered in return but what we
also see is Nick Fury speaking up and
Nick Fury says that he figured it was
only a matter of time before people
showed up to basically express their
sentiments or at the very least to band
together as a whole in response to the
distress call but he says the problem
here is that they're basically
contaminating the entire crime scene
that because of everything that's gone
on here because shield doesn't know how
all of this started that any of them
could be radiating any kind of toxins or
radiation in general and because of that
it could corrupt the scene in a way to
where shield could never figure out
what's going on and so what he says is
that everybody being here is illegal and
that they all need to disperse from here
we switch over to Carol Danvers and
Carol Danvers asked Captain America
whether or not it's true that Scott Lang
is dead and of course Captain America
says yes but what Captain America also
says is that he appreciates all of them
being here he appreciates all of them
Reese were responding right now he says
but for the most part Nick Fury is right
here
The Avengers don't know what's going on
and because they don't know what's going
on shield needs to be able to do their
job they need to be able to investigate
this situation and find out what else
taking place but what we do before we
continue any further is we pick up with
with Nick Fury again as he's basically
telling The Avengers there's more bad
news and when they ask Nick Fury what
this news is we pick up with a broadcast
from the United Nations and what the
United Nations is saying here is that
because of the actions of Tony Stark
that the United Nations is now
disavowing the Avengers they are
basically separating themselves from the
Avengers now the importance of this is
something that cannot be overstated and
the reason why is because for those of
you who were asking the question what
was it that happened that led up to
civil war this is one of the things that
had taken place as we discussed with
civil war there were a multitude of
instances where superheroes came into
conflict with supervillains they would
be destruction and so on and so forth
but nobody would ever be held
accountable this is basically the United
Nations holding the Avengers accountable
specifically Tony Stark for what it is
that he's said and done and so this is
the first baby step that leads up to the
set of events that will eventually
initiate the entire Civil War storyline
now the United Nations as they're
speaking are basically saying that the
Avengers have done some great things in
their past they have done some fantastic
things but the problem here is that the
actions of Tony Stark who was presumably
drunk who was acting irrationally who
would threaten multiple delegations and
it also for the most part attempted to
kill the representative of Latveria is
something that cannot be overlooked and
so because of this basically what's
going on is the United Nations is
playing it up playing it safe but what
we also do is we see that while this
broadcast is going on and everybody is
talking about it their attention is
taken away and the reason why is because
what we learn is that a Kree I guess a
Kree vessel of some kind has just taken
off past the team it has basically
entered the Earth's atmosphere and so
everybody begins to panic we of course
seem Nick Fury asking the shield
Helicarrier whether or not they're able
to detect anything and the shield
Helicarrier says no in fact they don't
really know what Nick Fury is talking
about they can't detect anything on
their radar which is an important
element because what it tells us is that
as far as the ship is concerned these
things are here and so again as the
Avengers are trying to piece all this
together is
to figure everything out when Nick Fury
instructs the individuals of the
Helicarrier to physically look outside
of the ship and look into the city they
realize there are different or I guess
there is a Kree ship that is appearing
but what we also find is that in
addition to this Kree ship is a Kree
warship an entire I guess a a fleet
vessel along with a host of a
person-to-person vehicles and so what's
basically taking place here as far as we
can tell is that the Kree are invading
the planet Earth and so what we do as we
continue with this is that we pick up
with the Avengers as they're doing what
they can is everything is going I guess
devolve into absolute chaos everything's
starting to go crazy
of course it's absolute pandemonium for
the most part they're dodging shots
they're trying to figure out what's
going on
and so what happens as this conflict
continues is that one of the Kree
encounters Captain America directly and
what Captain America does is he grabs
the Kree and tells the Kree soldier to
translate to tell them in English what
it is it's taking place and so what this
cream or tells Captain America is that
they're basically going to eradicate the
Avengers from the books of history
they're going to eliminate them entirely
that they are an affront to the Kree
Kola to the Korea culture and they need
to go away entirely in addition what the
Kree warrior says is that it was
foretold by their supreme intelligence
that a day would come when the Avengers
would come to an end at the hands of the
Kree now we don't know this for certain
but what this priest soldier says is
that this is the day this is basically
the reckoning of the Avengers at the
hands of the Kree and so what we see is
that all these priests soldiers begin
teleporting down onto the surface of the
planet and the fight begins to become a
I guess a ground fight it stops being an
aerial battle and so again we see that
Captain America we see Nick Fury we see
them talking about how this doesn't make
any sense how this isn't right but as
something I guess a little bit a little
bit of irony here if you recall our
discussion about original sin we had
talked about how during this time Nick
Fury was going around and killing
different creatures killing aliens
killing anybody who was presumed to be a
threat to the planet Earth and so if we
didn't know if this story had just come
out and we hadn't known what the outcome
was going to be with regards to the
Scarlet Witch we could say that it's
entirely possible the Nick Fury had
brought this conflict to the planet
Earth but of course as we see them
continuing as we see everything going on
we
see that that Hawkeye steps up into the
fray after retrieving his arrows and
what he says here is that it's time to
end this conflict this conflict needs to
stop that if the cream on to invade the
planet Earth then somebody should give
the Kree a reason to and so what he does
is of course using his arrows he begins
attacking the Kree warriors and he's
able to hold his own for the most part
he's able to do quite well against the
Kree soldiers and again as things
continue as things progress we
ultimately see that some of the arrows
or perhaps even Hawkeye is an actual
outfit catches on fire and when it does
Hawkeye begins to panic for a moment but
then he has this moment of clarity and
what he does is grab one of the Kree
soldiers who's wearing a jetpack and he
initiates the jetpack firing it towards
the mothership and when he actually gets
towards the to the mothership proper he
flies into one of the engine bays and
then the mothership explodes indicating
to us that Hawkeye had sacrificed
himself for the purpose of defeating the
cream at this point we pick up with with
the Fantastic Four we pick up with
Captain America we pick up with
virtually everybody who's a symbol here
as they're absolutely shocked to see
that Hawkeye has basically just
sacrificed his own life to ensure the
Avengers come out on top we also see the
other pre warriors begin teleporting
back to back to their various ships and
all the ships take back off again and so
what we do is we see that as things are
beginning to slow down that as a
conflict is beginning to come to an end
that one of one of the individuals one
of the members here is looking at the
Kree warship or I guess looking at parts
of the Kree warship and what they say is
that it's not really metal but they
don't know exactly what it is
whatever this material is it's not
native to the Kree it's not something
that we normally possess and so again
this begs the question this asks a lot
of questions of what it is it's really
going on here about what this whole
undercurrent is in terms of why all
these things are happening but again as
they're going through as they're talking
as we're trying to figure this stuff out
someone chimes in and apologizes that
they couldn't get here sooner and what
we learn is that dr. strange has
appeared to the Avengers and what dr.
strange says is that he would have he
would have
by now that people would have began to
understand that the problem here isn't
that the courier attacking the problem
isn't that Tony Stark was acting drunk
or that any of the other events have
played out the way they have the problem
is that magics are currently being used
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace